I mean,
it's like if you're in jail for five years and then like a gay guy walks in,
who's kind of dainty or like,
this is a wine winery vineyard that's it is a vineyard it's been
pouring rain. Now a Celine Dion is bumping.
I'm getting a little Misty and I think it's going to be a weird shows, got money
[inaudible] to be here and pry them. Make sure I say that. Right. I said,
Priyam earlier. I thought I said the N word pretty flipped out.
Since I'm too scared to ask for another water,
I'm going to fill this up in the bathroom. Like a psycho
for water for Christ's sake.
No dice guests were gone in that bathroom sink
came over here. We're sold out two shows. 5:00 PM, 7:00 PM.
Should it be interesting if I smoke half I'm good, but if I do the whole thing,
no, you're not supposed to inhale. Oh, Helen,
for years,
[inaudible] tested positive for the full hour.
We'll open with Corona and then go into the real stuff.
[inaudible] Hey comedy, huh? Yeah. NBA.
The seats are empty. How weird is that theory? I got an idea.
All those racist statutes and tore down.
Let's put them in the seats just to fill it up. You know,
I think that would motivate the players. LeBron's like, is that,
is that robbery Lee? All right. We're going to win this one.
He didn't have herpes before. You'll get it. Now. There you go. All right.
I'm joking. I don't have herpes. Just limited
urination. Thank you. Ooh boy.
Ah, I'm a real hole. Grace, the wet the bed. So, uh,
now the fake hand wash for the people at home,
go for these outdoor gigs.
You've got to just hammer them with punchlines or else you lose them because
there's no connection. There's no ceiling. So you just got to keep pounding him.
Corona, starting to feel like the check engine light in your car. At first,
it's scary. But after a while you're like, it. I got to go to work. Boy,
killing on the right left sides of book club over there.
This is lights out. I got cocaine over here. And then Tylenol PM
for you Jews right here. Huh? Saving the day. I was scrounging Burr for minutes.
Just trying to take up more time. We lost her again. Okay. All right.
All right. I thought you were doing, doing Coke. I was going to say, you know,
I get, it's a lot of bumps. She's a fun. Okay, good. Well,
me photos of whatever you guys scissor. Um, cool.
He's a fun girl. Huh? I was out of stuff. I was just tap, dancing up there.
I had nothing. It's a scary feeling.
Just doing the cliff is at your back and you got to think of something.
There's actually people staying in this hotel. They must be like, Oh,
there's that cult again? Just sitting out there drinking.
Isn't getting awkward. Huh? But up here too long,
it feels like we all and I won't leave. Thanks a lot.
I'm Kevin Hart and you guys are great. Have a good night.
[inaudible] Let's see what this beer is all about.
Love your sober down the drain.
That's another gig and the books we pulled it off. We'll see you in hell.
[Inaudible].